an upper gi endoscopy also called an
esophagogastroduodenoscopy
or egd is a procedure that allows your
doctor to view the mucosal lining of the
upper portion of your gastrointestinal
tract this includes your esophagus
stomach
and duodenum
upper endoscopy is used to evaluate
symptoms of persistent upper abdominal
pain nausea
vomiting bleeding or difficulty
swallowing
it can accurately detect inflammation
infections tumors ulcers and other
problems that may be present the
procedure is performed using an
endoscope which is a long thin flexible
tube with a light and a tiny video
camera attached to the end the camera
transmits an image to a monitor
before the endoscopy an intravenous line
will be started and you will be offered
pain medication and a sedative your
blood pressure pulse and the oxygen
level in your blood will be monitored
during the procedure
your doctor may spray your throat or
have you gargle with a local anesthetic
that will numb it you will be asked to
lie on your left side and a supportive
mouthpiece will be placed in your mouth
in some cases you may be given
supplemental oxygen through a nasal
cannula
uncomplicated upper endoscopies take
between 10 and 20 minutes your doctor
will gently insert the endoscope through
your mouth and then slowly and carefully
move it down your esophagus until it
reaches your stomach
and finally your duodenum you should
feel no pain as this is happening your
doctor may periodically introduce a
small amount of air to flatten the
mucosal lining and improve visibility if
your doctor would like to collect a
sample of tissue he or she will obtain
one or more biopsies through the
endoscope for later examination a biopsy
will help distinguish between benign and
cancerous tissues it is also used to
detect helicobacter pylori the bacterium
that may lead to ulcers your doctor may
also use the endoscope to treat a
problem such as an actively bleeding
ulcer or to stretch open a stricture or
narrowing in the esophagus or stomach
after the procedure you will be
monitored until the effects of the
medications have worn off your throat
may be sore and you may feel a bit
bloated you will need to arrange for a
ride home afterwards
you